welcome everyone to brilliant minds bold
questions
a five-part virtual series exploring
questions being addressed by some of the
world's top researchers
each talk pairs speakers and moderators
from across disciplines
sectors and the world to explore the
questions shaping our future
if you are not familiar with us cfar is
a canada-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity
my name's mark daley and i'm vice
president research at seafar
it's my pleasure today to introduce you
to cfar associate fellow dave bacon
and cfar fellow stephanie simmons
stephanie is an assistant professor at
simon fraser university
and the canada research chair in quantum
nanoelectronics
dave is vice president software at ion q
and an expert on quantum error
correction
today we will explore the question is
the future of computing
quantum today's session will last 30
minutes
and i'll ask our speakers questions and
we'll also be taking questions from all
of you joining us today throughout the
session
if you have a question please submit it
through the q a function at the bottom
of your screen
let's get started first question
where is quantum computing at today
right at
this moment what can a quantum computer
do for me that a classical computer
can't
who should jump in so i think you just
volunteered stuff
yeah so um there's a lot of discussion
about
all the things that quantum computers
are going to be able to do that
classical computers cannot right so
there's all these wonderful
examples of worked examples of things
that
quantum computers are going to be able
to do such as you know break
cryptography but simulate quantum
systems and all these there's there's a
long list and if you are interested in
you're on the technical side you can go
to quantum algorithm zoo
um search for that it gives you the big
one list uh
we are not at that full large scale
thing in fact it's actually
phenomenal that we can see that that's
where it's going given where we are
we're just kind of
passing the hello world stage almost
we're seeing we're able to do things
by we i mean the community not
necessarily like
me but like the community has been able
to demonstrate a
few things that uh a few computational
challenges that have not been able to be
done
are met uh as quickly let's say on on
classical systems
but i think in that context people
typically forget the other cool things
that quantum technologies are able to do
um not just from a complexity sense like
not just in terms of like this is how
hard it is to compute a thing but
for example quantum computers quantum
devices are able to teleport information
there's no there's no way that you can
do that with a classical system there's
all these like little neat things like
you can't
um copy quantum information so there's
there's little things that
uh quantum little things there are quant
there are things that quantum
technologies can do that classical
systems
you just never can do and so we're at
this stage where it's it's going
commercial
i gotta pause there because i know dave
has a lot to say on the matter but
but basically yeah it's at this really
wonderful tipping point where we're
it's starting to really come alight
right like this the smoldering and it's
soon gonna
burst into flames i love that
characterization of it's smoldering
okay so dave on the topic of going
commercial do you want to pick up
yeah i mean i didn't talk a little bit
about that i think one thing that i
always think is funny is we
often times we hear that quantum
computing is like we're sort of the fact
that some people will say we're like at
the bad engineer of the computer
right or some people say we're just at
the invention of the transistor
or some people say it's more like the
integrated circuit what's kind of
happening
is that i feel like those are usual it's
very useful to look at history and
especially the history of classical
computers
but the chart that quantum's taking will
likely be different
so and an example of that is you know it
is true that we have very small quantum
computers you know
uh google's function computer is not
very large ideas they're very
few number of qubits right so they're
not super powerful right now
but there are other interesting
challenges that occur in the field so
for example
in commercialization one of the things
we have to do is we have to get all
these
to work together at the same time and
programming that until we get that to
work is a lot like
the 80s actually in the very weird
parallel
computing architectures that people try
to build um
and so that's about it because we try to
understand what it is
but it's sort
i think the thing we probably could
agree on is that it's an exciting time
because we're able to do these
experiments now
for larger systems and for more
coherences and we're just in different
headings
to that point
and places where we wouldn't expect it
to be useful i think we're just getting
more and more control over the common
world
and in that respect it's extremely
exciting because it's just
it seems like nothing creepy we don't
see sort of our limits there
um you know we may stall out at some
point who knows but it's we sort of see
that
i mean when we talk about the actual
commercialization then it gets even
crazier because then of course money
enters into the field and all sorts of
crazy disciplines because people are
you know want to make money off of this
eventually right
i will say that in the field i've been
in now two quantum computing companies i
was at google and then i'm at this
company inq that does science computing
i would say that well from the external
point of view you do a lot of classes on
internet and stuff like that internally
the people are all just
trying to build the damn thing and get
it to work
and trying to do the best thing they can
right and so it's a weird sort of world
where
there's a public frothing at the mouth
whereas internally there's a lot of like
this is a really hard thing that we're
trying to do
and everybody involved wants to figure
out how to do it and you know the best
people are
are looking at each other and trying to
learn from each other uh and so
it's really in my view i had like these
two different
things going on and they kind of freaked
me out in some way but that's sort of
the
sort of the way the community works so
i love that connection back to the the
parallel architectures of the
the 1980s you know i'm imagining the old
connection machine
and there was that sort of pre-cambrian
explosion of different architectures and
ideas and we're
sort of going through that in the in the
quantum realm right now
yeah that's that's great okay no go
ahead
i mean that's why i love that analogy
is because i wanted to growing up i
wanted to participate in that when i was
a little kid
so you're getting your wish
this is a human habit right like this is
how disruptive technologies tend to go
it goes through this this you know
incubation period within academia
and then there's this mass proliferation
of
approaches and what's going to come next
right like if you can use that as a way
of predicting the future what comes next
is a giant consolidation event and a
massive talent shortage so
if you want a really nice nicely paying
job get really good at quantum computing
because there's a there's going to be a
big
talent scramble where everybody kind of
when the
there arrives a dominant design where
people
forms consensus around what the actual
winning horse is gonna look like
and it's it's gonna be in the next
couple years i think
so all the young people listening take
stephanie's advice
learn quantum computing
every day i'm bombarded by papers
press releases and honestly i can't
always tell the difference between them
uh about breakthroughs in in quantum
computing
how should i as a non-quantum specialist
be evaluating these claims
this is hard like the usual sort of
things always occur which is you can
you can try to listen to the experts who
are saying things and you can hear what
they're saying
but even there it's always challenging
because we don't really you know for
example in industry we don't really know
what's going on
you know i know what's going on right
now
and so it's really hard to get an idea
about what's going on the breakthrough
thing is always a little bit
wonky right like it it's just
it's hard to say and tell you know
it's nearly impossible to judge
breakthroughs in this green bay weird
way right and so i think
almost all of them when they say
breakthrough you're kind of skeptical
but it could be that somebody had a
great idea that's going to change things
i mean we have seen events
in quantum computing that are in
somewhat breakthroughs right so this is
there's an invention of an architecture
called architecture which is predicting
cubic
and you can see at the breaker because
like all the other types of people are
doing sort of like dissipated and that's
not totally true there's still lots of
interesting things being pursued
but it was it was such a performance
improvement that like immediately kind
of being used by tons of people
who could get it you know the reason
that that was the breaker right and
that may not have been obvious and i
don't think it was obvious when the
paper came out and i'm not sure what to
press release
so
it's it's fortunate that we haven't gone
fully over to
um commercial metrics so you can still
use
um publications and the
uh who's invited to like the big
conferences it's kind of a proxy
it's not a great proxy but if i were to
actually try and give advice to somebody
who isn't
like i didn't know the space they'll be
like well is this person well cited do
they publish
in like high high-profile journals are
they invited to high-profile things
it's not great it's better than nothing
in terms of a proxy
because there is and will continue to be
a lot of
proliferation in the space where people
claim to be able to do things that they
can't
and and and trying to read that out is
is going to be really hard so at the
moment there's still this academic proxy
right where like quality is kind of
gauged by these publications
that's not going to last forever right
like through this evolving um
commercialization phase we're gonna
start having
performance metrics that become
standardized and
people start being able to report upon
them commercially these those are gonna
be broadened beyond the ones that exist
today because there's still gonna be a
lot of stuff that we need to figure out
on how to properly characterize uh and
and put things around these systems but
yeah i would say if anything that would
be the bit of advice i would give to
people
trying to learn the space which is not
great but it's better than nothing
the other thing i like about this
question though which is sort of the
hidden thing was
is that there isn't necessarily
consistent consistency across the field
the field is still
i mean the thing that i hope people are
trying to do is talk to each other and
continue to debate things this is hard
stuff
and you know we don't because we don't
know what the future things are going to
look like
there will be a diversity of opinions uh
one of my favorite quotes is is by terry
rudolph i will win
everybody but from the extent of like
the look that all of us are working on a
particular
approach to quantum computing because
that's what we did absolutely and
there's some truth to that right like
there's goodness about that like being
an expert in something and pushing that
as
possible is great but i don't you know
there is a lot of diversity in the way
that i can see the future unfolding and
i think that sometimes we
we forget that there are competing ideas
and people who are trying things and
people may believe that this is the way
they do it it turns out it's wrong
right it goes the wrong way right and
that that's actually fine it's just hard
for us to do that because we want to be
able to see what the future is and what
where things are going and
i think we just we struggle with that
because that's nearly impossible
right so i think we sort of sometimes
beat ourselves up
when thinking about this too much um but
it is important to try to make sure
like i think the biggest thing is trying
to pull back to reality make sure
that people are validating what they're
doing like this is clearly something
that
everybody in the field needs to do and
you know
that people are still publishing papers
that's probably the healthiest thing
that can continue to occur
dave that's a it's a really good point
you know as as researchers
you know we've sort of learned by
experience that
you're going to fail at just about
everything you try because it's research
and every once in a while you'll have a
success and so in an early stage like
this
there's a lot of people who very
passionately believe things that are
potentially wrong but uh i really like
stephanie's intervention
of you know there's no single right or
way right or wrong way to
to tell what you should look at is
community consensus
if if a large group of people all with
passionate ideas think oh that's
probably worthwhile it's probably a good
good proxy which is not to say
the winning horse has been well
identified right like this is the whole
point is that there will be
things that come from left field and
there will be breakthroughs
and they won't all look the same right
they'll probably look very different so
it is a bit of a wild ride and you can
keep your eyes open but yeah
it's it's to try and distinguish what's
worth paying attention to
versus what's not worth paying attention
to that's the proxy i would use
and you need that proxy once the number
of papers on archive starts becoming
literally inhuman
i used to be uh so i used to be able to
read every single quantum paper that
came out or at least stim
it um when i first got going and there's
there's just no way that's gonna happen
there's and it's even hard to train to
stay on top of all the news
articles from all the companies that's
not even talking about yeah
it's fun it's a wild ride it's a wild
ride that's where you want to be
okay so let's extend the wild ride out
it's 2050
and cfar has reconvened this panel for a
reunion
do i still have to ask you the first
question or are quantum
computers now ubiquitous and a familiar
part of our world
and if so what would those technologies
look like and
what societal changes might they have
ushered in
i think they're going to be boring i
think that's what success looks like and
i'm an optimist well no like think about
it electromagnetism used to
convene things like this you know
there'd be people that have workshops
and they would go and sit in in
big halls in the royal society in
england and people would look at how mad
magnets work and that would be an
evening experience right and that's just
now it's electromagnetism is as boring
as you plug something into the wall and
it just works and it will it'll just
work and it's going to be a long
trajectory and it's going to work under
the hood in a way
i think may many of the the big ones are
um the kind of cloud services that are
supporting uh
so much really important research today
it's under the hood nobody's you know
you're not walking around downtown and
you see a big giant
you know cloud services thing that like
pops into your consciousness it's just
supporting
the broader infrastructure of humanity
and it's going to be like that
and and if it's successful even the kind
of quantum communication things in your
cell phone which may eventually come
like that is still going to be to the
point where you're not going to have to
like
know about it the like if we're lucky
all it will be is like a little local
logo like powered by quantum and that's
like the extent of it right so that's
that's my
optimistic streak i love it success is
boring
well i mean that's what commercializing
a branch of physics is yeah right it's
taking it from being
something that is synonymous with magic
to being something that's useful
and routine and a tool
yeah i mean there's there's the
commercial future
they're also i mean there are
alternative realities that i think are
fun to think about right
so there are things where like maybe
quantum mechanics breaks in some weird
way along this journey
right and this is one that the total
possibility and people will bring up
uh you know people there are people who
are very skeptical who bring it up and
then you have to sort of try to engage
with them and understand what they're
trying to say
but this is one possibility right and i
think one of the things
that's weird is to me is that that like
that that one weird probability so maybe
it would all fall
that could happen right like we have to
acknowledge it it's not a
impossibility right now um so that's one
weird question like it could be like oh
man
it's time when you were super optimistic
and then all of a sudden you discovered
mechanics is
broken in network that's something
different in this weird way and then
likely the story is oh and then we use
that in some way right or something else
right so it's unclear that that like is
the end of the story so there could be
some future like that
um there could be some future in which
like um
you know it could be that you know the
real question is do we get to the point
where we stall
out you know usually what people always
bring up even though you know right now
to me it appears that fusion is
undergoing a huge explosion of
interesting work
sort of a revival even though you know
if you started long ago the writer's
gonna come back
and people are doing that so it could be
that it stalls out in some weird way for
reasons that we don't quite see right
now uh and then we're kind of limiting
that
right and trying to figure that out i i
just i put that in low just because i
just don't see them right now i see a
new fourth approach which goes
pretty fast right you would think maybe
there are
we will likely laugh at the brute force
approaches that are being taken right
now like being through
what i mean by blue forces you know
individual control of
single qubits with ion traps or you know
bigger again
circuit that they need to put together
in this air correcting code to build a
larger quantum computer like that
very brute force and technology the
darkening technologies have sort of
really done that particularly well
that's hard right like
you know it may be that we look back at
this era to be like oh this is before
they discovered
you know specifically really good
quantum [ __ ] i'll call it that
you know quantum system that does this
and it's now obvious that that was the
right solution
and we kind of laughed that there as
like the you know these people who are
trying this
this amazing thing like we sort of do
this when we look at early computing too
right but there are these crazy things
that people trying to build
right some of our storage devices back
in the early days were just nuts
right but but it turned out that like
they were on the they were
all doing great work but they just
didn't scale in the right way
i mean like we as human creatures we
take what we know
and we adapt it much more than we invent
right and so
like it's going to be true that the
first cars look like horse-drawn
carriages and that's fine we shouldn't
we shouldn't like laugh
at it really like we should be like you
know that was what was known at the time
and
and honestly i think it's actually a
tour to force some of the stuff that's
coming out that's demonstrating what it
is
with with all of those caveats in mind
like with all of those constraints and
the rest of it is heroic it's heroic
stuff
and it's definitely paving the way for
more venture funding for other things
you know like there's there's
it does service the overall dream of
this rising tide lifting all boats
because it will be a computational
resource that will be used across
across the board right like just across
the board and so having that
and anything that unlocks that even like
culturally
um conceptually should be celebrated i
think
stephanie i love your optimism for human
ingenuity
we're we're pretty persistent
we are so i have trust that
people have at least some motivation
fueled by one mechanism or another to
make it happen right especially when
it's known when you can kind of see
like the the road map a little bit not
the path story but like the the
mountain that needs scaling yeah or
people are pretty
uh persistent all right i've got some
good questions coming in from our
audience here so
i i'm going to turn over to them steven
asks there are many applications for
quantum computing and one of these is
cryptography
will quantum computing mean the end of
security by cracking security algorithms
or will quantum offer new approaches to
security that cannot be cracked by
simply increasing the number of qubits
there's a type of cryptography that
people call post-sponsored cryptography
which is
the idea to do things that are resistant
to a large quantum computer
now what's fascinating is cryptography a
lot of our crypto systems are based on
the hardness of the homes
but the classical example is short
either factoring a number
is far uh and though the hardness method
gets the security
guarantee now why didn't we believe it
was hard but we believed it hard because
a lot of smart people were trying to
come up
with things that failed there's some
other things going on there but it's
roughly that
uh and then peter short came along and
said hey this weird computer can break
it
pokemon cryptography is sort of now in a
similar situation where they
they have some cryptosystems that
they're trying to develop it should be
secure
and the idea right being that like smart
people are thinking about this and
they're trying to choose problems that
are resistant to a quantum computer but
again we're now back in this
processing that there's no way to break
those cryptosystems and i think that
the jury on this is a little bit out and
we're at the beginning of this
the scary thing that if you want to put
it in terms of the fear
right the thing that's kind of scary is
that a lot of the photography that's
used right now not just
like the internet one's easy i used to
write google software today right like
going into changing google's
infrastructure in terms of internal
stuff to use different
systems it's a lot of work
but it's like not a major scary thing
but if you think about all the
cryptography that's used in the wilds
on the like the internet of things and
that you can't just upgrade
right like it's often uncreateable and
it's going to be with us for
say 10 20 years then you have to stop
worrying about those types of systems
being broken because they don't already
have this
postponed cryptography the other part of
this story is just but there are things
like
there are other quantum cryptographic
principles like on key distribution
that can be used and i think that's i'm
less of an expert in it but i just
you know there are there is some way in
which there are other benefits
they're not necessarily uh they're not
it's not
sort of this like quantum cryptography
stalls all the things the shores
algorithm breaks that's not
quite correct for my understanding but
there are these other photographic
principles
there's actually probably a lot of them
working out there that we're still
trying to understand
it's kind of this there's a just there
are people who work in sort of these
weird
distributed systems and trying to think
about uh you know how do you think
they're
in interesting ways and
cryptographically secure ways
maybe their way the quantum community
could benefit there um and i think
that's probably like if i were young
i would be like oh that's a fun place to
work in because i don't see it i don't
see a ton of people thinking about that
but it's definitely a club field that
exists
where people are really trying to think
of what interesting cryptographic print
it is
yeah so so qkd and these other tools are
are
not reliant on the principle that
something is hard to compute
it's relying upon physical principles so
it's not as if it's resist they're not
as if
as if a quantum computer can necessarily
break it right so
it is it is very much it offers it
offers one and
takes you know it's if you have to um
think about both sides of it
but teleportation like the information
does not travel through intervening
space it's a very different way of
thinking about the
movement of information and cryptography
more broadly so
lots of opportunities there
interestingly
the technology that's going to be used
to unleash
that is kind of similar to what a
small-scale quantum computer is going to
look like so a repeater isn't going to
be so different
you know it's going to have you know a
lot of similarities with small-scale
quantum computers so it's going to kind
of come in intent
but there is going to be um yeah a bit
of a
onboarding to a new protocol that can uh
withstand
or withstand shore's algorithm so
stephanie
on that point james asks you mentioned
the
teleportation aspect of quantum
computing so information teleportation
does it look like that aspect will be
useful in addressing latency
and and can you imagine a world where
our communications infrastructure is
entirely quantum
so those are two separate questions
latency is an easy one in that
there exists um kind of bounds on what
uh that means in terms of information
propagation so
you can uh you when you when you
teleport information quantum information
the information is actually teleported
but it needs like a tidy up
um signal you need to be able to send a
signal to be like okay well
but it's it's correct but like up to a
sign
and you need to like fix that sign
basically and so that still involves a
signal that needs to be sent so it
doesn't change the latency so much
um which is kind of this wonderful
boundary condition
uh in terms of how the laws of physics
all work because
you can have this this beautiful effect
that
um that seems to go faster than but not
you can't signal faster than light and
that like nuance is enough to
um yeah keep a whole bunch of other uh
uh things from from going wrong
from a physics perspective
so what what do you see in terms of
modern communications infrastructure so
we're still
we're still bounded by the speed of
light so do we just use classical fiber
optics and we we never have quantum
communication oh no we will um we
absolutely will
there's a there's giant satellite
programs underway their telecom is going
to be able to support
quantum communications the repeater
stations are going to look different
um there will be i imagine you know
that's
so there are these quantum safe
approaches but i will say
that you know the only thing that's
truly truly quantum safe is going to be
some amount of quantum key distribution
or similar like something where you
teleport information
uh to some level right like some people
will really insist upon that level of
security
and there's because some of the
algorithms that people have put forward
as you know something that ought to be
secure against quantum
attack have fallen right like people
have found
uh ways through so it's one of these
things that you know i imagine they'll
have something
but not just from a communications
perspective but from a distributed
computing perspective
like quantum computers when you combine
them the reason why they're so
powerful is because when you combine
them it's much more than some other
parts they combine and the space that
they encode grows
you know exponentially in the qubit
number and so
like two ten qubit systems joined
together is so much more than
like it's it's so much more than just uh
the sum of the parts
so you're going to need to have
distributed quantum information
if we wanted to really leverage
large-scale quantum computing resources
across
large distances you know if you needed
to rally that together for whatever
large-scale computation
you're going to need to be able to send
quantum signals and teleport stuff
around just for the computing sake
so that's going to be part of our future
you know like it sounds amazing to say
but it's absolutely going to be part of
our lifetime these are
these are going to be happening on some
small scale and then growing bigger and
bigger and yeah distributed quantum
computing is going to be happening on
the cloud and again it's going to be
boring
i love it dave i have a question that
looks
tailor-made for you from dawn when
quantum hardware
architecture becomes stable are we
likely to see a huge change in how
software is written what software
architectures will we likely see
as a response to quantum hardware
and it's in the top question we're very
we're in the very early days of
writing quantum software it's very you
know it's very much like
the stuff you do with the high levels
very much like assembly language
they're like hidden layered there's sort
of two layers that people talk about
they're sort of like programming the
quantum computer up here maybe through a
cloud interface
and then there's like the software you
need to write to get the quantum
computer to run
all operating systems to me there's a
ton of back maybe work going on there
it's a little bit
more of it's hidden because a lot of
it's being done against industry groups
but
a lot of really fun challenges to get
that system to even work right
that's part of the one of the hidden
things i can remember the day of google
when we were running this
beyond classical experiment where one of
the stoppers
came in and he was like it looks like
it's going to be able to scale up to be
you know perform what it does it was
just like he was like you could see the
relief sort of knocked off the shoulders
so i i suspect right now we're just at
the beginning stages of understanding
how to
run these very simple things we are
admitting a level of solutions
that can help us build algorithms or do
things correctly i think i think we're
i think we've always been looking for
these in quantum computing people
working in quantum algorithms to
understand them
there are some of these alternative
models that people trying to come up
with
and they could give a new way to think
about that i sort of believe
i'm hopeful that we're at the beginning
of people starting to think
you know trying to develop these weird
things to help us and guide us in
and building new algorithms that's
really challenging
right but again you have to think back
to history of algorithms and just notice
that like that that didn't occur in
places
i thought there was a conference
recently that i didn't know existed but
i just learned
that it's on simplicity and algorithms
and i love that this idea that sometimes
simple algorithms and explains it
algorithm that come out
into input very important and i feel
like that's one of the things that i'd
love to see more of in quantum computing
ways that we can conceptualize the model
that help us do new things
um and i think popular would be a big
part of it i do i do think that sort of
this
this mipping hole and you know what i
think i'm excited about our tools to
help us do that by building tools for
people to try to explore space and
understanding
and this is this is challenging but if
you think it's going to be part of our
story
um the good thing is it's the beginning
right the stuff that we've written in
quantum
software is very new that's a lot of fun
too because you'd be like oh i'm doing
this new thing that nobody's thought of
before to do in quantum computing
so that makes that feel very fun
thanks dave stephanie i'll give you the
last word before i have to wrap up
on on the note okay so on the note of
hardware and software development
there's a giant giant opportunity for
co-design i don't think we're only just
kind of getting into it but
um yeah there will be as you're saying
this dominant design emerge
and or a few dominant designs maybe that
emerge it'll coalesce around a few
and there will be lots of opportunities
for co-design where you start thinking
about
you know through the software stack
compiling down to actual hardware and
optimizing on that and so that's why
there's a lot of really
interesting developments happening in
the corporate side because
within the academic side usually things
are
quite uh agnostic hardware agnostic and
they're kind of done in general to be as
broadly applicable as possible
but there's a lot of opportunities for
optimization and really
you know unleashing things when enough
people across the entire stack are all
working
and and having the higher end of the
stack informing the hardware too right
like that it's not just a one-way street
it's up and down and so there's there's
oh my gosh it's fun it's so much fun
i'm so sorry to say that is all the time
we have for today
i would like to thank all of you for
joining us and special thanks to
stephanie
and dave for sharing your insights and
optimism
for a boring world with us
please visit our website cfar.ca to find
out more about the series and to view
recordings of previous talks
a recording of this talk will be posted
by early next week
[Music]
you